يعني الاوضاع كما تشاهد امامك في الصوره
استهداف واسع النطاق طالا العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف وعدد كبير من المدن هنا
امامنا في الشاشه همم الشرطه الادله
الجنائيه تقوم بجمع الادله من مقام وقوع
الانفجار في منطقه بورنشي هذه المنطقه
وهذه القريه التي تقع في ضواحي العاصمه
العاكييف الاستهداف همم يعني نتيجته دمر
عدد من المنازل لم تسجل همم
ولكن هنالك ثلاثه اصابات نقل الاشخاص
المصابين من هنا الى العاصمه الى داخل
المدينه لتلقي الرعايه الصحيه هنا عمال
الانقاذ ايضا يعملون لمواصل التفكير هذه
المنازل والبحث تحت الارقام اذا ما كان
هنالك اي ضحايا في موقع الحادث الانفجار
الذي وقع هنا هو ليس الوحيد في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف هنالك ايضا في غدار نستوي
والمنطقه بيتشيرسكي هنالك انفجارات هنالك
ضرر اصاب احد المشروعات الصناعيه ايضا في
العاصمه كيف افاده السلطات السلطات كيف ان
هنالك 16 صاروخا توجه نحو المدينه كيف دمر
الصواريخ السته عشر وهذه الاصابات هي
نتيجه همم الشظايا التي سقطت ما عدا
الاصابه هنا في هذا المكان او الضرر هنا
في هذا المكان الذي نتج عنه سقوط صاروخ
مباشره هنا في هذا الموقع طبعا الاستهداف
كان واسعه عن نطاق العاصمه وايضا مدينه
الفيفا التي الان هي 90% من المدينه تعيش
دون كهرباء وايضا هنالك انقطاع في المياه
في عدد من احياء المدينه كذلك مدينه خارقه
التي سجل وصول اربعه صواريخ هذه ليست جميع
الصواريخ التي تم استهداف المدينه بها
ولكن هذه التي استطاعت الوصول الى اهدافها
في مدينه خارقه وايضا نتيجه ذلك انقطاع في
التيار الكهربائي
هيتوقف المترو وكذلك سجل تدمير 21 صاروخ
في سماء مدينه اوديسا والتي ايضا الان
تعاني من انقطاع فئه التيار الكهربائي
وانقطاع في المياه ايضا مدينه اااه نيكا
لايف واوديسا وجيتومر وشيرنيجا وهذه المدن
لم ااه يعني لم ااه استطاع الدفاع الجوي
ان يدمر جميع الصواريخ التي استهدفت هذه
المدن
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه